>> DO YOU HAVE ANY PLANS TO
VISIT THE BORDER.
>> I -- AT SOME POINT -- YOU
KNOW, WE ARE GOING TO THE
BORDER.
WE HAVE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
SO THIS WHOLE -- THIS WHOLE --
THIS WHOLE THING ABOUT THE
BORDER, WE HAVE BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
WE HAVE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
>> YOU HAVEN'T BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
>> AND I HAVEN'T BEEN TO EUROPE.
[LAUGHTER]
I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW -- I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE POINT YOU ARE
MAKING.
I'M NOT DISCOUNTING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE BORDER.
BRIAN: NEVER GETS OLD.
LAWRENCE: LET'S BRING IN LARA
TRUMP, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, LAURA.
>> GOOD MORNING, GUYS.
AINSLEY: THERE IS A REPORT THAT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS NOW
CONCERNED AFTER THEY WATCHED
THAT INTERVIEW.
SHE HAD HER FIRST INTERNATIONAL
VISIT AND THEY FEEL LIKE THAT
INTERVIEW IS OVERSHADOWING IT.
THAT IT HAS DOGGED VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS FOR THE WHOLE
TRIP AND STOLE THE SPOTLIGHT
FROM HER.
THIS IS CNN REPORT ON HARRIS'
TRIP.
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
ENDURED A ROCKY FIRST FOREIGN
TRIP SINCE TAKING OFFICE WITH
SOURCES TELLING CNN HER TWO DAY
SWING THROUGH MEXICO AND
GUATEMALA LEFT ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS QUIETLY PERPLEXED
ABOUT WHAT THEY PERCEIVE AS HER
BUMPY ANSWERS TO QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER SHE WILL GO TO THE
U.S.-MEXICO BORDER.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
STEVE: THAT'S CNN.
>> YEAH.
THAT'S CNN.
BY THE WAY, GOOD POINT.
I THINK WE ARE ALL PRETTY
PERPLEXED.
I MEAN, I GUESS THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU HAVE A BORDER
CZAR WHO IS CLOSING IN ON 80
DAYS SINCE SHE HAS BEEN TASKED
WITH ADDRESSING THIS PROBLEM.
HAS YET TO GO TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THAT INTERVIEW WAS AN ABSOLUTE
DISASTER.
WHAT AN EMBARRASSMENT.
I HAVEN'T BEEN TO EUROPE?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
ANYTHING?
AND WE HAVE BEEN TO THE BORDER,
WHO?
WHO HAS BEEN TO THE BORDER?
BETWEEN JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA
HARRIS THE TWO PEOPLE APPARENTLY
IN CHARGE OF THE COUNTRY.
IT IS A RIDICULOUS THING.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE, GUYS THAT
THIS WOMAN WAS ACTUALLY A
PROSECUTOR.
SHE HAD TO KNOW SHE WAS GOING TO
BE ASKED THESE QUESTIONS.
AND THEN SHE IS SO NONCHALANTLY
TRIES TO BRUSH IT OFF.
THIS IS A CRISIS.
WE HAVE SEEN IN A YEAR WE HAVE
674% INCREASE IN PEOPLE COMING
OVER OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
THERE WERE 180,000 APPREHENSIONS
LAST MONTH ALONE.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THEY
CAUGHT.
THINK ABOUT ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
CAME IN.
YOU GUYS SHOW THE VIDEO ALL THE
TIME PEOPLE JUST WALKING ACROSS
THE SOUTHERN BORDER WITH NOBODY
THERE TO STOP THEM.
IT IS RIDICULOUS.
OBVIOUSLY IT IS EMBARRASSING FOR
AMERICA THAT THIS IS OUR VICE
PRESIDENT.
STEVE: YOU KNOW, SHE DID GO TO
THE BORDER WHEN DONALD TRUMP WAS
PRESIDENT, WHEN SHE WAS A
SENATOR TO SEE WITH OTHER OWN
TWO EYES HOW THAT ADMINISTRATION
WAS IMPACTING PEOPLE.
NOW, SHE IS ACTUALLY PART OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION BUT SHE
WON'T GO DOWN TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER TO SEE WITH OTHER OWN TWO
EYES HOW IT'S IMPACTING THE
PEOPLE.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THOSE
IMAGES OF PEOPLE WADING ACROSS
THE RIO GRANDE, THOSE PEOPLE ARE
TAKING THEIR LIVES IN THEIR
HANDS IN SOME CASES TO TRY TO
GET HERE.
SHE IS NOT GOING TO GO DOWN TO
UNDERSTAND THE ROOT CAUSES AT
THE BORDER?
THAT SEEMS A LITTLE OFF MESSAGE.
>> IT'S RIDICULOUS.
IT'S INSULTING TO AMERICA.
IT'S INSULTING TO THE PEOPLE
THAT LIVE ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
IT IS RIDICULOUS TO ASSUME THAT
THESE PEOPLE IN THE BIDEN-HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION ARE DOING
ANYTHING AT ALL.
THEY ARE NOT, IN FACT, THEY
REPEALED WHAT DONALD TRUMP AND
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAD
IMPLEMENTED THE POLICIES THEY
PUT IN.
THAT WORK AND YOU HEARD THE
PRESIDENT OF GUATEMALA TALK
ABOUT IT HE SAID.
BRIAN: LARA WE HAVE THAT CLIP.
SARA CARTER INTERVIEWED THE
PRESIDENT OF GUATEMALA
YESTERDAY.
LISTEN.
>>
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
BRIAN: SO IF YOU ARE NOT CLEAR
ABOUT YOUR MESSAGE, I'M SORRY
FOR EVERYONE LISTENING ON RADIO.
IF YOU ARE NOT CLEAR ABOUT YOUR
MESSAGE, IT'S GOING TO BE A GO
SIGN FOR PEOPLE TO COME TO
AMERICA.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN CLEAR.
IT'S EASY FOR REPUBLICANS TO
CRITICIZE REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS AND VISA VERSA.
WHEN ANOTHER COUNTRY'S PRESIDENT
IS TELLING YOU HIS REALITY, YOU
HAVE GOT TO PAY ATTENTION.
HARD TO MARGINALIZE.
>> YEAH.
AND WHEN THAT PRESIDENT IS THE
PRESIDENT OF A COUNTRY WHOSE
PEOPLE ARE PART OF THE GROUP
THAT ARE COMING TO OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER HE IS TELLING YOU THE
REASON THIS IS HAPPENING IS
BECAUSE OF THE POLICIES AND
BECAUSE OF THE MESSAGING FROM
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS.
I MEAN, I TALK ABOUT IT ALL THE
TIME, GUYS, BUT DON'T FORGET
THAT THEY HAVE TOLD PEOPLE IF
YOU COME HERE, YOU WILL BE ABLE
TO STAY HERE.
WE WILL YANT YOU AMNESTY.
WE WILL GIVE YOU FREE
HEALTHCARE.
WE WILL ALLOW YOUR CHILDREN TO
STAY.
WHAT PERSON IN THEIR RIGHT MIND
WOULD NOT SEE THAT AS A CLEAR
SIGNAL TO COME NOW, COME TO
AMERICA NOW.
THIS IS YOUR CHANCE.
SO THEN THEY TELL US WELL, WAIT,
BUT THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
SO DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
WE ARE NOT THAT STUPID,
AMERICANS CAN VERY CLEARLY SEE
THE PRESIDENT OF ANOTHER COUNTRY
CAN VERY CLEARLY SEE.
IT'S A REALLY SAD SITUATION.
THEY HAVE TO GET A HANDLE ON
THIS.
I DON'T THINK THEY WANT TO GO TO
THE SOUTHERN BORDER, GUYS, FOR
ONE REASON, BECAUSE IT WOULD
DRAW MORE ATTENTION TO THE
ABSOLUTE CRISIS THAT EXISTS
THERE.
BRIAN: YOU SEE IT, YOU OPEN IT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO OWN IT HER
POLITICAL OPERATIVES TOLD HER TO
STAY AWAY INSTEAD OF JUST